she got it no problem go Kate
go here head over there head over there
go there okay there yeah look at her go
we damn know all the planes we flew good
things we've been through that I'll be
standing right here talking to you about
another path
now Kate over there go check that out
Kate get into position you keep saying
no problem with there clearly it's a
problem Kate what is it hold position
need something I want to talk about our
relationship could be worse you would be
better what do you want report ah your
thoughts I see how you're looking at me
I don't like it just thought it clear
the air Oh
alright follow me I'm on it ha ha ha ha
ha ha ha ha
stay there ah Mon oh yes move here go
Kate
up there move out Oh get good go bit
move over there get that move over there
Oh get it go get that you clearly don't
got a cake there you go girl
add a key you spin my head right round
right round of here there you go that's
my cane whoo go girl
Elias to stop it there's no stopping KT
Khun down the hill Go Go Kate come on
hey go no [ __ ] you stupid shame on you
I've gotta oh god you're ugly votes for
Arnold
go back to sleep the [ __ ] are you doing
sit down boy hey mate
see a like this
geez how did that ruin his leg that guy
gives zero [ __ ] just drinking his
coffee didn't see anything
let's punch his toe whoops
whoopsie whoopsie okay oh oh oh
promise you'll vote for me now it's not
so fast uphill Oh what the [ __ ] is this
whoa [ __ ] off mate oh sure make me carry
more of your junk well well look who's
back
you learn how to walk all right I think
you need to do some Pilates or as some
sort of exercise you seem a little stiff
don't worry that there's still hope we
have some medical treatment that just
wonders just state to stay there right
there right there let's hold position
now hold that position and
not sure if that worked not sure right
let's try that again all right we need
to get into safe distance all right here
we go
Jesus how far away do you have to be
what happens if he shoot down in the
ground
she made it but what do you do I want to
see how the explosion looks like
ah ah
ah
crazy and crash that's awesome Oh No
alright so now Potter we have a new babe
coming after us you jelly let's talk
about our leadership candy cat for your
thoughts I just wanted to check in make
sure things were all right between us I
suppose things are alright just feels
like we could be doing more for folks
out here you know
oh [ __ ] I'm so sorry
hey Piper please vote responsibly oh
[ __ ] what happened here me oh oh oh ah
ah hey it's a party
Oh mate whoa home run baby that's how
it's done baby
that's dead no one sees Arnold weren't
for your two-timing games
no one sees him
little bound change you got beat up by a
girl I'll just run back home to dead oh
no don't like talking well I like your
dress actually I don't like this very
much
Arnold feels fabulous alright crust
thank you for watching I'll have to end
this episode here really fun to play
let's see what happens with Arnold in
the next episode thank you for living
and like support this series I'll see
you in the next one
stay awesome rush holy [ __ ] fight me
like a man
oh no don't like
while you run [ __ ] come back here I
punch your ass